guardsman
yes sir welcome everybody we're jumping
right in because this hearing is in
progress
just got done filming today's show we'll
have time for more discussion
momentarily
uh let's listen your time in iraq at any
time in your uh
military service did you change how you
defended the person to your left or
right or how you trained with them based
on their political affiliation
no whether it was in war or anything no
no sir my the way i view it
at that time it was i'm an american and
the person right next to me is an
american
and i would do everything possibly for
me to defend
him and the country at that time you
guys did that
you guys did that in the blue yes sir
and i want to say that is the mission of
this committee
we may have our deep differences on
other policy issues
but we are all americans today and we
thank you for holding that line
congrats congressman if i may if i may
respond to uh
congressman um
when you asked about the armed part when
the officers
assumed officers showed me their what
appeared to be a police badge
i don't know too many police officers
and this is just me being a police
officer for 13 years
that carry their badge and don't carry a
gun with them
so i look we look on their hips you see
a print
i didn't see that it was a gun but a
reasonable police officer would believe
that that's a gun on their hip
so and just to quickly be specific a
print is basically what looks like the
outline of a gun
that's correct thank you mr chairman and
thank you witnesses
thank you gentlemen years back checker
chair recognizes the gentleman from
california
mr schiff thank you mr chairman um
i was on the house floor from the
beginning of the joint session
until the attack and evacuation by the
capitol police and i want to thank you
um i'm convinced that one of the lives
you saved that day might very well have
been my own
we are all greatly in your debt uh you
are all heroes
uh sergeant gennell um representative
lofgren asked you about your experience
and i won't ask you to repeat that
i would like the public to see from your
perspective
uh some video if you're comfortable with
my showing it yeah that's fine
uh if the clerk could uh roll the video
please
[Applause]
do you know how to lock them together
here like this
to these shields you know how to put
your arms
we have a hard plate guy here you
show them how to lock the shields
together and hold the shields
we need an avenue of escape so wait to
lock this one in
go ahead
[Applause]
stop stop stop
can you imagine
sergeant in that video
one of the first things you hear is
someone saying you're going to die
tonight
you described in your opening statement
being crushed by rioters you could feel
yourself losing oxygen thinking this was
how your life was going to end
trampled to death defending the capital
um it's hard for any of us to understand
what you went through even though we
were there
uh it's even harder i think for people
around the country to understand what
that was like
can you tell us what you were thinking
when you were losing oxygen and thought
that might be the end
my rushing out there another way i was
thinking is like
we can't let these people in no matter
what
even if it cost my life um
well that had bloody hand that you saw
that's me in there and
both hand both my hands were bleeding
bad
at no point in time did i stop to
consider
stop because the attacks were so
relentless that
all we had to do is i was thinking was i
need to survive this
if possible but i'm willing to sacrifice
myself
to prevent this uh the attack attackers
from coming in
i swore enough and to protect
the public the member of congress and
the united states constitution why not
and that's what i was doing that that
day regardless of my personal
safety along with everybody else that
was there that day
they were calling us traitors even
though they were the one
doing committing the treasonous act that
day
wow um it is
devastating and demoralizing for
people who everybody is
to call this attack and
continued to minimize it like nothing
happened
it was an attempted coup that was
happening
at the capitol that day and
if it would have been another country
the u.s would have sent
help right and and
people need to understand the severity
of
in the magnitude of the event that was
happening that day
we were all fighting for our lives to
give them
to give you guys a chance to go home to
your family to escape
and now the same people who we helped
the same people who we gave them the
borrowed time
to get to safety now they're attacking
us they're attacking our characters
they're attacking
officer harriet character people who
never serve in the ca
in their military or in as a law
enforcement
it says disgrace
my actions that day was
to save you guys regardless of my
personal safety and i still continue to
to
wanting to do that today tomorrow and
as long as i'm premature to do it and if
it is if it is demanded
of myself to do that in the future
sergeant um this obviously had a deep
impact on you
uh all of you um but it's also had a big
impact on your family
uh you described how when you got home
you couldn't even hug your wife because
you had chemicals all over you
um you wanted to go back uh it seems
like no sooner had you gotten home you
wanted to go back
yes um i think i read that you said you
felt guilty
um did your wife want you to go back no
why did you go back
and and and what was your conversation
with her about that
after i took a shower uh
i spent about 10 minutes hugging her and
my son
um she i told her i gotta
get some sleep because i got to go back
to work and she said no you're not
you hurt i said no i'm still
able to continue to carry out my duties
and by eight o'clock i was already on my
way back
despise despite her concerns
and for my safety my
sense of duty for the country for the
constitution
at that time was bigger than even my
love for my wife
and my my son why put that ahead
and well for me
it's confounding that some people who
have sworn off
elected officials including people in
the military
that i seen at the lower stairs fighting
against me
they sworn off and they're forgetting
about that off
they're not putting the country before
the party
and that's what bothers me the most
because i as a former
soldier i know what that inherits that
wolf
and i was willing i'm still doing
willing to do that
and we got people right now
in front of the justice department is it
possible to move the captions so we can
see the titles and everything
people to be released
even though we are testifying about the
trauma and the agony everything that
happened to us
it's pathetic yeah i think i'm going to
turn these off i'll let the official
anymore
officer dunn
you described talking to your fellow
black
officer about what you went through and
experiencing those
racial epithets you asked a question i
think
that i've been haunted by ever since is
this america
and i'm very interested to know
your thoughts on the answer to that
question
is this america what you saw
well uh thank you for your question um
you know i
i said this i've done a few interviews
before about what
my experiences that day and i said that
um
it was a war that we fought and a war is
composed of
a bunch of different battles and
everybody
even sitting at this table fought a
different battle that day but it was all
for the same war
um and as black officers i believe we
fought a different
battle also and um
the fact that we had uh our race
attacked and just
because of the way we look you know
to answer your question frankly i guess
it is america
it shouldn't be but i guess that's the
way
that things are i don't condone it i
don't like it
but i mean if you look at our history
of american history things are
countries existed because they beat
they want a war or colonies and state
lines and boundaries exist because of
violence and wars like so i guess
it sounds silly but i guess it is
american and it's so
but it's not the it's not the side of
america that i like
it's not the side of that any of us here
represent we represent the the good side
of america the people that actually
believe in decency and human decency and
we
appeal to just the good of the good in
people
that's what we want to see whether we
disagree with
how they vote on a bill about
infrastructure
everybody wants the right thing
people to do okay so that's why i'm glad
to see this committee composed of
republican members also
so i i i that's encouraging
it's encouraging so that's the side of
america that
i say yes this is america this is the
side that i like and the side that i
acknowledge so
officer thank you um i believe in this
country
and i believe in it because of people
like you
who understand what the flag means and
what our constitution means
and risk their lives to defend it
i'd like to thank uh you've been
watching live coverage of the first
hearing by the house committee
investigating the january 6th capital
attack the testimony today from four
police officers i'm gonna find like a
clean stream here hopeful it's been
personal detailing the
the verbal and the physical assault they
endured that day one officer here
recalling thinking to himself
this is how i'm going to die wiping away
tears as he finished his remarks
another saying that the pro-trump mob
beat him and threatened to kill him with
his own gun
and a third a black officer there
describing repeatedly being called
a racial slur on the steps of the
capitol that day among
the ones today's most powerful moments
the dc officer michael fanon slamming
his fist on the table
condemning the republican lawmakers who
in his words deny
or downplay the riot republican leaders
as you know are boycotting the
investigation calling it a sham
but two republicans want to extend my
gratitude and appreciation
for your service on january 6th and
since then which you've had to go
through
i was on the house floor like my
colleagues on the sixth when i was told
that a violent mob
had breached the capitol and it's
because of your service
it's because of you and your colleagues
that we're here
today because you were literally the
last line
of physical defense laying your life on
the line
for democracy my time will be limited so
i'll be asking questions of
officer hodges and sergeant gannell
primarily about the weapons
that you observed and how they were used
officer hodges you were in a unique
position because you were down
constitution you were closer
to the white house to start as you
indicated in your testimony
during the morning in the early
afternoon on the 6th
what did you hear specifically about
guns and explosives
that had been discovered by your fellow
officers
i i was listening on the radio to our
gun recovery unit working the crowd um
what the what we usually try to do is
wait for the crowd to disperse before
making a rest that way we don't set off
the crowd and set off a riot
um so i think they might have identified
people of interest
um that they never got a chance to
address and
they were working the crowd to try and
confirm
reports of firearms on certain people
but it's also difficult to do given the
nature of the crowd and
how many there were when i heard
reod confirmed the existence of a device
there was only one thing it could be you
know explosives
um and but we um
in 42 we had our own our own objective
our own mission
so we couldn't really um we we scanned
the crowd
but um these people you know they know
how to conceal their weapons
so on a big avenue like constitution
you can't really it's difficult to
detect the print
or if it's in a backpack there's really
not much you can do
but uh we we um you know we continued to
scan the crowd and
find what we could uh but mostly it was
up to our
other units to make those um discoveries
you you talked about in in response to
to representative cheney you talked
about the gear
that the individuals were wearing so
combined with
what you saw visually with what you had
heard
on the radio um about guns
um that that all kind of led you to give
pause about
the next few hours correct absolutely um
you know once we got to the capitol and
um
and we were fighting i i was
i was wondering you know how many more
bombs are there
um how what's what's the trigger is it
is it going to be a cell phone
is it is it a timer
how many guns are there in this crowd if
we start firing is that the
signal to them to set off the explosives
however many there are in the city
is that the signal for them to break out
their firearms and shoot back
so that's the reason you know
why i didn't shoot anyone and i imagine
why many others didn't
because like i said before there were
over 9
000 of the terrorists out there with an
unknown number of firearms and
a couple hundred of us maybe so we could
not
if that turned into a firefight we would
have lost and this was a fight we
couldn't afford to lose
i want to play a video and i'd ask that
everyone
watching pay attention specifically to
the weapons the rioters were using
you can hear someone yell get your
machete
you can see officers being attacked with
flagpoles
flares and gas canisters it was a
peaceful protest though they said i
thought
taking rocks bottles and pieces of flag
you had a pulse
cruiser 50 the crowd is using the
missions against us
they have their spray in the crowd they
are spraying the crowd
that's peaceful guys they're supporting
the police
[Applause]
sergeant gannell in the video we just
saw someone throw a large speaker
uh was that directed your way i was
i was further inside uh that was
afterward towards the end of the
before they got clear when they threw
the speaker at
me and uh i was for the inside the toner
what types of weapons did you see used
against
your fellow officers
police shields police baton the hammer
slash hammer that you saw on on that
video
uh flag poles tasers
pepper spray bear spray rebards
bats
pvc pipes copper pipes
rocks uh table legs
breaking broken down furniture broken
down
the guardrails
for the inauguration stage cones
uh 4x4
any weapons any items that they could
get in their hands on at that
you were you were further down the
corridor but the speaker was thrown at
you
um and it and it hit your foot is that
correct all right sir
uh we have a uh photo it was thrown my
way
and then when landed it hit somebody
else and they hit my foot
i think we have a photo of your of your
oh my god as well that we'd like to show
all right
can you tell me how you're doing you you
mentioned in your
in your opening statement about your
continued physical therapy
um related to the related to the foot
can you tell me how you're doing
um the foot i had a
several conditions that were
one is uh fusion on
number one metatarsal
uh tart tarsal metatarsal
then it was a hamato that as a result of
the hit
and then the second and third digit also
got
um damage
and in order for to fix one they needed
correct the the big toe uh to stabilize
if not i would later on the future would
have had the same
problem come returning um
it is very painful it is
with a lot of patience and determination
that i had gone through i still had the
same
problems uh in terms of pain and
stiffness what not
the doctor last week on tuesday told me
that i'm gonna knee surgery on my
shoulder because
i have a labrum tear that has not healed
even six
more than six months later and possibly
my
uh rotated cough also was going to need
some work so that you're talking about
eight months to to a year more of
physical treatment in
rehab sergeant you're
an immigrant from the dominican republic
a naturalized
us citizen and you mentioned how
individuals had
zeroed in on your on your race
um that day oh god you tell me how that
how that made you feel when we were
aft before or right after
uh mpd just arrived with the
fluorescent uh mountain bike unit
they got there i was at the front line
and
they apparently they seen even through
my mask
they saw my skin color and said you're
not even an american
regardless whether i was
yeah but some woman at trader joe's was
forced to wear a mask while
shopping i mean everybody has their
things going on right guys
me i mean when i heard that i wasn't
even thinking about
any racial stuff i'd like okay you don't
know that
for fat so i'm not even entertaining
that
but it's just like officer harry
uh done it takes time for you to process
that
and you only realize what was happening
after you go back and
see it from a different point in time
because
i only saw that recently but for me
i wasn't even thinking about it i'm
there to stop them
regardless i'm not thinking
what what they were yelling in terms of
my skin color
my race and i know an american soul a
soldier and former
soldier and a police officer they
certainly weren't yelling we love
hispanics i can assure you that
when i was defending all of you guys um
officer hodges you characterized the
attack on the capital as a white
nationalist insurrection
can you describe what you saw that led
you to label
the attack that way
the crowd was overwhelmingly white uh
males
um usually a little bit older middle age
older but
some younger i think out of the entire
time i was there
i saw just two women
and two asian males everyone else was
white males
they're
they didn't say anything especially
um xenophobic to me sounds like antifa
but to uh my black colleagues and
anyone who's not white and they would
some of them would try to
try to recruit me one of them came up to
me and said are you my brother
um oh my god there are many uh
many known um organizations with ties to
white uh supremacy
who had a presence there you know like
three percenters of keepers that kind of
thing
and um
everyone i've ever
people who associate with donald trump
are uh find more likely to subscribe to
that kind of belief system
that's a fact not an opinion thank the
four of you for taking the very
difficult step of
sharing your stories and your
recollections of the threats
violence that you endured no one should
have to experience what you went through
and this committee will continue its
work to give a complete accounting
of what happened to protect further
officers
and to amplify the stories that you've
shared today thank you so much for being
here yield back mr chairman
wow i get gentlemen yields back she i
recognized
young lady from florida miss murphy for
five minutes
thank you mr chairman and thank you to
the witnesses
um for your testimony today for your
bravery
on january 6 and for your service to our
country
i know all of you endured a great deal
on january
6th and i know we've watched a lot of
difficult
video in this testimony so far but i
hope it's okay with you if i
i show a brief video of what officer
hodges experienced that day
can you please cue the video
[Applause]
okay
oh
[Applause]
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
[Music]
yes
that's a peaceful crowd wanting to learn
about the history of our sacred
democratic institutions why wouldn't the
police let them learn
officer hodges i know that must have
been difficult to watch
um but i really think it's important for
the american people to see that
because that's the beginning of the kind
of accountability that this committee is
committed to
in order for us to do what you said
moving forward as a country
um you know january 6 was an attack on
our democracy
it was an attack on the peaceful
transfer of power and it was an attack
on this
capital building but it was also an
attack on real people
and most people don't know this um
and i don't think even you know this um
but your actions had a profound
uh impact on me so at
3 pm on january 6 while you were
holding back the mob at the lower west
terrace entrance
i was holed up with congresswoman
kathleen rice in a small
office about 40 paces from the tunnel
that you all were in
that's about from the distance where i'm
sitting here on the dice to that back
wall
and from that office in close proximity
to
where you all held the line i listened
to you struggle
i listened to you yelling out to one
another
i listened to you care for one another
directing people back to the makeshift
eye wash station that was at the end of
our hall
and then i listened to people
coughing having difficulty breathing
but i watched you and heard you all get
back into the fight
and i think congresswoman rice and i
were the only members of congress
to be down there um on that lower west
terrace you know we had taken refuge in
that office
because we thought for sure being in the
basement at the heart of the capital
was the safest place we could be and it
turned out we ended up
at the center of the storm
and officer fanon you had said you know
you were 250 feet
off of that tunnel and you felt certain
that they were going to kill you
imagine if they had caught the two
members of congress
that were just 40 feet from where you
all were
and i know uh sergeant gennell and
officer hodges
you both said that you didn't realize
that other parts of the capital had been
breached
but you really felt like you were the
last line of defense
well i'm telling you that you were our
um and during the exact period of time
officer hodges in that video where you
were
sacrificing your body to hold that door
it gave congresswoman rice and i
and the capitol police officers who had
been sent to extract us
the freedom of movement on that hallway
to escape down the other end of that
hallway
and i i shudder to think about what
would have happened had you not held
that line
you know i have two young children i
have a ten-year-old son and a
seven-year-old daughter
they're the light of my life and
the reason i was able to hug them again
was because
of the courage that you and your fellow
officers showed that day
wow and so just a really heartfelt thank
you
um i think it's important for everybody
though to remember
that the main reason rioters didn't harm
any members of congress was because they
didn't encounter
any members of congress and they didn't
encounter any members of congress
because law enforcement officers did
your jobs that day
and you did it well i think without you
what would have been a terrible and what
what was a terrible and tragic day
would have been even more terrible and
more tragic
so just very grateful for all of you
and now i'd like to talk a little bit
about that video
um you've talked a little bit about it
in your opening statement but
can you um walk us through what
is happening in that scene my
understanding is that is a mix
of your body camera as well as video
from other
um vanished points that's correct
um at the beginning you see me walking
into the capitol that was after we were
driven off of the west terrace
um i think you'd see me uh spit on the
floor unfortunately
um trying to clear my lungs and mouth of
all the cs and oc
um you see me uh preparing my gas mask
donning it
ready to go back out there and i
followed the noise
to the tunnel where um
it was just you know wall-to-wall people
packed
fighting for with everything they had um
it was full of oc and cs gas at the time
and i believe that thickest smoke was
from a fire extinguisher you could see
all the residue
on um on the officers who were there
um and it's like i said before you know
we they had you know they outnumbered us
50 something to one so it didn't matter
how many um how many we defeated
we just had to um we had to hold on we
couldn't let anyone uh
can let anyone through and they could
they always had a
relative you know um essentially an
infinite number of replacements
they'd say you know we need fresh
patriots up here
and there would be more so we just had
to hold
until someone came to help
um and like i said once i got to the
front
i didn't want i didn't want any more
pressure
on the officers behind me so i
tried to insert myself to where i could
use the door frame brace myself and push
forward
so it could take back more territory
unfortunately that
backfired so once we lost ground
i was unable to retreat i was uh crushed
up against the door frame
um and and um
in my most vulnerable moments um
the uh the man in front of me took took
advantage
and beat me in the head
ripped off my gas mask straining my neck
skull
split my lip open um
just everything he could and it was
economic instability guys
at that point i uh i recognized that
if i if i stayed there then i was gonna
you know pass out from lack of oxygen or
get dragged out into the crowd and
be end up like fanon um
so i i called for help you know i
tried to make it clear that you know my
position was untenable i had to fall
back
and thankfully the other officers heard
that were able to get me out of there
and um to the back where i uh
recuperated as best i could before i got
back out there again
well it's clear that you suffered
immense i'm sure outside the building
there's
lots of trumpists saying we back the
blue here in support of these officers
right that would be the right thing to
do
again tell me what what's worth all of
that pain what was worth it what were
you fighting for that day
democracy um you were 40 feet away
40 yards whatever um
if especially with the razor thin
margins
on democrats and republicans in the
house and senate
if any single one person was kidnapped
or killed which i have no doubt in my
mind is what they intended
that would affect the outcome of
legislation
and and all your uh
duties for years to come
and if that's just one person
what if you know more than one person it
would the difference would be even
greater
than what should be and will be
um
and for obviously for each other you
know you you um
your immediate concern is the well-being
of your colleagues
the other officers who were there
fighting beside me
i think i can speak for everyone i say
we worry about each other more than
ourselves that's just in our nature
it's part of why you become a police
officer
you know like when fanon said he was
trying to find out who needs help
and no one would volunteer that's just
an example of that kind of uh
mindset that we have so it was uh
it was for democracy it was for the men
and women of the
house and senate it was for each other
and it was for the future of the country
thank you officer hodges and thank you
all um
for uh defending democracy
and um i appreciate your testimony
and i appreciate your continued service
with that i yield back general lady
yields back
chia recognized gentleman from maryland
mr raskin
thank you mr chairman sergeant canel
officer fanon
officer hodges officer dunn you are
great law enforcement officers and a
hero to law enforcement officers across
the country
you're a great public servant you're
here to public servants across the
country
but you are great americans and you are
heroes to
all of america and i wish that were true
you are gone
i wish that were true be remembered as
heroes to our country
along with your fellow officers and
those who attacked you
and those who beat you are fascist
traitors to our country and will be
remembered forever
as fascist traitors now officer dunn
i've got to start with you because
you're my constituent
you are the pride of maryland today
because of the way you stood up
for the capital and for the congress and
for our democracy but you said something
fascinating in your testimony you said
you never seen anybody physically
assault
a single officer before in your 13 years
on the force much less thousands and
thousands of people
attacking hundreds of officers so
how did you experience that when it
first happened
while we listened i'm just gonna look
for this story on foxnews.com about the
hearing i've seen videos of officers
being attacked and
people resisting arrest but to clarify
it's never
been the assaults on the skills that we
have seen
like that before um
i just wanted to clarify that can you uh
repeat your question well actually it
leads to my next one actually
um you made a really interesting point
you said you'd seen protests
for many many years you'd seen even
civil disobedience
for many years there's an effort today
to portray the events of january 6
like some kind of uh resurrection of dr
king's march on washington
in 1963 you know and i've seen a lot of
protests here too
i've seen i know the stream is up here
guys thank you that the young people did
about gun violence i see people marching
for d.c
statehood arguing for their rights to
representation
in congress and i've seen civil
disobedience
but was this like any of those rallies
or marches or demonstrations you'd ever
seen and if not what was different about
it
so while the the marches that you the
protest that you specifically talked
about
i'll go a step further and talk about
the not so
one the ones that had the potential to
be not so peaceful
you had the um million man march rally
uh
the 20th anniversary of it um
it was a lot of opposition to that you
had the clan
that came up here you had people that
were pro guns that wanted to come up
here
so all of those had the potential to be
very
violent and frankly quite deadly uh
but they did not um on
this wasn't the first time that if i can
just use this quote the maga people came
up here to the capitol before
they were in dc before there were some
skirmishes
but it was never the attempt to
overthrow democracy they came up i think
this was
maybe their second or third time that
they had come up on january 6
and even then as belligerent as they
were
it didn't account to this violence so
the only
difference that i see in that is that
they
had marching orders so to say um
when when people feel emboldened
by people in power they they assume that
they're right
like the the one of the scariest things
about
january 6 is that the people that were
there even to this day
think that they were right they think
that they were right yes
and that that makes for a scary recipe
for
for the future of this country um
so i think that's why it's very
important that you all
take this committee seriously and get to
the bottom of why this happened and
let's make it never happen again thank
you um officer fanon
um i think you've given our committee
our marching orders today which is to
hold the line
you held the line and now we've got to
hold the line so i want to thank you for
that
if we show a fraction of the courage and
the valor
that you all demonstrated on january 6
then we will hold the line
in this committee but i want to ask you
about holding the line
and i want to go back to this question
of weapons so we can clear this up
because there are still some people who
are saying that the that the
insurrectionists were unarmed
and i wonder what your reaction is to
that because we've heard about
well first of all rampant baseball bats
lead pipes um confederate battle flags
and so on
and what about the question of firearms
so what is your reaction generally to
this proposition that they weren't armed
whoa solid beard wow first and foremost
i would say that the implements that you
just described
are most certainly weapons with regards
to firearms
i know that in the days
immediately before the january 6th
insurrection
and january 6 itself firearms were
recovered
by law enforcement from individuals in
washington dc
who were believed to have been
participants
or at least those who were planning to
participate
in the january 6th insurrection
and yes those were firearms handguns and
such
um but forgive me for these questions
but is that a north carolina accent
in some nether regions of the internet
it's being said
that uh you officer fanon maybe were
mistaken for antifa
and that's why you were nearly beaten to
death that day and carried in the
crowd is there any way you think you
were mistaken for antifa
well i was in full uniform uh
i was like i said wearing my uniform
shirt adorned with the metropolitan
police department's patch
i had my badge on until somebody ripped
it off my chest
i do not believe i was mistaken for a
member of antifa
um you mentioned your testimony that
there's some people who would prefer
that all of this go away that we not
have an
investigation let's let bygones be
bygones but you seem pretty determined
to get the country to focus on this why
is that so important to you
uh well first and foremost uh because of
the actions
of officers who responded there that
this doesn't sound like texas to me this
is a totally different accent than like
george w
bush and some of the surrounding
jurisdictions
um you know downplaying the events of
that day is also downplaying those
officers response
and like sergeant gennell said some of
the officers
part of the healing process from
recovering from the traumatic events of
that day
is having the nation accept the fact
that that day
happened some people are saying that uh
that as public servants you all should
not be
speaking out that cops firefighters
teachers
should just serve the public but should
not speak out
as citizens what do you think about that
officer finally
um well i disagree i've been outspoken
throughout my career
uh never to this magnitude um as an
undercover officer and a narcotics
officer i've preferred
uh obscurity in the public eye
however this this event is uh
something that we have not experienced
in our lifetimes
officer hodges um i read your testimony
carefully
i hope every american reads your
testimony but i noted that you referred
to
terrorists or terrorism 15 different
times by the way raskin himself has a
you
when when he says the word fire he says
fire
i think that might is that a maryland
thing do people know
guys and so on um however some of our
colleagues have been calling the violent
insurrectionists
not terrorists but tourists
why do you call the attackers terrorists
and what do you think about our
colleagues
who think we should call them tourists
well if that's what american tourists
are like i can see why
foreign countries don't like american
tourists
oh god but i can see why someone would
take issue
with the uh title of terror that's the
same thing that was going on at piazza
navona last time it was in rome that's
just what tourism is guys
past few decades and uh we like to
believe that no
that couldn't happen here no no domestic
terrorism no
homegrown threats but
i came prepared u.s code title
18 part 1 chapter 113b is in brown
section 2331
the term domestic terrorism means
activities that
involve acts dangerous a human life that
are a violation of the criminal laws of
the united states or of any state
and b appear to be intended
to intimidate or coerce a civilian
population or
to influence the policy of a government
by intimidation or coercion
or to affect the conduct of a government
by mass destruction assassination or
kidnapping
and occur primarily within the
territorial jurisdiction
of the united states well thank you for
that
and um i had one final question for
sergeant gennell but looks like my time
is up so i'll yield back to you
kia will give the gentleman opportunity
to
ask thank you for your indulgence uh mr
chairman
um are there questions sergeant gannel
that
you hope we can answer as a committee
about the causes of the attack the
nature of the attack and what happened
in the weeks
prior to january 6 as we develop our
work plan moving forward
i think in my opinion um
we do need to get to the bottom of who
incited
who brought those people here
why the people were made to believe
that the process was rigged
along those lines
but going back to what i just said
i had in my 15 years of service
i had given thousands of
uh i had given tour to thousands of
people
at the capitol as an officer as a
sergeant and even in
plain clothes uniform
at no point in time did i ever get got
attacked
i don't know why how would you call
an attack on police officer a tour
when you see me bleeding my hand the
tour guys come on
getting concussion getting main
getting fingers
shattered i got gouche
it's indescribable you're defending the
undefensible
and it demoralizes not just
the ranking file but the future future
recruits
that we are trying to get so what we
what do you think people considering
becoming law enforcement officers think
when they see
uh elected leaders down playing this and
why would i risk my life for them
when they don't even care they don't
care what happened to the public
they don't care what happened to the
officers all they care is their
job their position if they not
if they don't have the courage to put
their job
on the line because they want to feed
some lies or not to feed somebody's ego
or like for a tweet that's not putting
the country
first we are willing to risk our life
but at least make it worth it we are
trying we
we do that regardless whether
you're a republican democrat dependent
we don't care when
when there's a call radio call or
dispatch sends a call we don't ask
hey by the way before i treat you before
i take care of
are you a republican or democrat or
independent
we don't we just respond and normally in
under any other circumstances we just
stay
shut we don't talk about politics we
don't talk about what happened to us
but this is bigger than that you
downplaying an event that happened
to the country itself
to democracy to the rural law
you're talking about people who claim
that they are
pro law enforcement pro police
pro law and order and then yeah when
they have the chance and the opportunity
to do something about it to hold
people accountable you don't
you pass the bucket like nothing
happened and it's so
devastating for recruiting
yes we need bodies right now but this
makes it harder
especially when trying to attract the
talent that we need
people who are willing to risk their
lives to protect you guys
well thank you very much sergeant
gunnell and mr chairman you know the
question was asked by officer dunn is
this america
i think these gentlemen embodied the
spirit of america and we must do
justice to their sacrifice in the work
of our committee i yield back
no question about it chair recognizes
general lady from virginia
miss lauria thank you mr chair
and i want to say uh to the four
officers here today that
i'm grateful for your service
for you sharing your stories for your
willingness to speak
to the members of this committee and to
the american people about
the horrific things that you experience
on january 6
truly experienced in defense of our
democracy
sergeant gennell we talked earlier and
you mentioned the many times that you
took the oath
both to become a naturalized citizen to
join the army to serve as an officer
of the capitol police force and
officer hodges you mentioned as well
as a national guardsman and as a police
officer and you know myself
something i i can't share with you the
the horrific experiences that you had
that day
but all of us having taken that oath and
and i took it
when i was 17 and joined the navy in
over two decades
you know sergeant gone when you
mentioned
and compared this earlier to the
experiences that you had in iraq
that in a war zone
you didn't feel like you felt that day
can you can you share that with us in a
little more detail what was going
through your head your
thoughts about what you would experience
defending our nation on foreign soil and
then being here in the heart of our
nation and our capital
and being assaulted the way that you
were
um it is very disappointing
in terms of like when you see when i was
in the lower
west terrace and i saw
many officers fighting for their lives
against people writers
our own citizens turning against us
people who had the blue light thin blue
line
on the chest or a
another rider with a marine hat that
says veteran
or any other type of military
paraphernalia why not and then
they're accusing us of betraying the off
or they the one
restrained the off when i was in iraq
the sense of command conradity
it didn't matter whether you were white
black
spanish middle eastern we all
knew what we were fighting for and my
experience there
was the there were times that i was
yes i was scared of going on convoys
or doing my supply mission to
the local iraqi population because i
need to point we were
possibly ambush or
getting shot at we knew the rest
but he was simultaneously over
over and over our own citizens
while they were attacking us because we
are were defending
the very institution that they are
claiming
they're trying to save well
thank you for sharing that and i know it
it's been difficult today
as we've watched these images from the
capitol but
i i did want to share one more
video but this time i would i would ask
people you could even
like close your eyes and listen without
watching
just listen to what is being said as
these brave men
were being overrun
[Applause]
you're on the wrong side of freedom
i thought they supported police you
can't even call yourself american
you broke your nose today 1776
[Applause]
so officer fanona i i wanted to turn to
you
and when you hear the writers chanting
things in this video
things like f the blue you can't even
call yourself an american
you're on the wrong side of freedom can
can you share
how that makes you feel
again i think when i you know my my
response that day and
at no point that day did i ever think
about
the politics of that crowd even the
things that were being said
did not resonate in the midst of that
chaos
but what did resonate was the fact that
thousands of americans were attacking
police officers who were simply there
doing their job
and and that they were there to disrupt
members of congress who are doing their
job
you know in retrospect now thinking
about
those events the things that were said
it's disgraceful that members of our
government
i believe were responsible for
inciting that behavior
and then continue to
propagate those
statements
things like um you know this was a
or that police officers
who fought risked their lives and some
who gave theirs
were redcoats
and traders
to me those individuals are
you know representative of the worst
that america has to offer
thank you and and
thinking about the events that happened
on january 6th and thinking about
what led up to that day i i was reminded
of a quote
um a quote that i frequently heard used
from
hemingway that asks you know
how do these things happen how do things
like
this happen and that quote it's very
short
it just says gradually
and then suddenly and i think that our
founders understood that our republic
was
very fragile and it would be tested and
it was tested here
on january 6. you know in 20 years
i don't want to look back on this moment
and think that we saw these signs coming
gradually
that these were signs that we ignored
that signs that people thought were
just isolated incidents or or signs of
things that we thought
could never happen and and i don't want
to say to my daughter
or sergeant gannel to your son or
officer fanon to your four daughters i
don't want any of us to say that
this happened gradually
and then suddenly
and that that some were just too worried
about winning the next election to do
something about it or too cowardly to
seek the truth
so that's the task before this committee
i'm sure that we'll be attacked by
cowards
by those in the arena those only in the
stands
well yeah and that will be attacked by
people who are
more concerned about their own power
than about
the good of this country but but my oath
your oath all of our oaths here today
to protect and defend the constitution
against
all enemies foreign and domestic
will be our guiding light for this
investigation
and as officer dunn said earlier
you said we can never again allow our
democracy to be put in peril
so i will say that that we will
persevere we will
do what is right and our nation is truly
ever grateful
to you who held that line
your actions on january 6 could very
well
have been what saved our democracy
and we thank you
gentlelady mr terry thank you
uh the gentleman from maryland asked a
question
in terms of uh what
uh you would expect this committee
uh to do in our body of work
the sergeant grinnell grinnell
responded but we didn't give the other
three members an opportunity to kind of
tell us
based on uh the last 202 days of your
life
what would you uh task this committed
uh in its body of work what would you
like to see us do
uh offices for known i'll start with you
oh yes sir so while i understand that
there have been uh
investigations into
the events of january 6th my
understanding is that those have
addressed
some of the micro level concerns
that being the immediate security of the
capitol building itself
also the forced mobilization of officers
that day
uh planning and preparation and training
and equipment concerns uh
a lot of you know the events of january
and the days proceeding
i guess it's in it's interesting and
from a law enforcement perspective
as a police officer a lot of these
events happen in plain sight
we had violent political rhetoric
we had the organization of a rally
whose title was stop the steal and that
that rally occurred
on january 6th with which i don't
believe was a coincidence that on
january 6th
members of congress you here in in the
room today were charged with
tallying the electoral votes and
certifying the election
of our president and in the academy we
learn about
time place and circumstance in
investigating
potential crimes and those who may have
committed them
and so the time the place and the
circumstances
of that rally that rhetoric and those
events
to me leads in the direction of
our president and other members
not only of congress and the senate
but that is what i am looking for is an
investigation
into those actions and activities
which may have resulted in the events of
january 6th
and also whether or not there was
collaboration between
those members their staff
and these terrorists
thank you very much uh officer hodges
i think uh fanon hit the nail on the
head there
um as uh patrol officers
we can only you know deal with the
crimes that happen on the streets
the misdemeanors and occasionally the
violent felonies
but you guys
are the only ones we've got to deal with
crimes that occur above us
i need you guys to address
if anyone in power had a role in this if
anyone
in power coordinated or aided or abetted
or tried to downplay tried to
prevent the investigation of
this uh terrorist attack because we
can't do it
we're not allowed to and i think um
the majority of americans are really
looking forward to that as well
i believe we're heading towards a pause
at that point i'll get caught up on
messages from everybody and and other
things
thank you chairman um
there's been a sentiment that's going
around that says
everybody's trying to make january 6
political
well it's not a secret that it was
they literally were there to stop
the steal so when people say it
shouldn't be political
it is right it was and it is right
there's no getting around
that
telling the truth shouldn't be hard
fighting for fighting on january 6th
that was hard
showing up january 7th that was hard
the 8th the 9th the 10th all the way
till today
that was hard when the fence came down
that was hard we lost our layer of
protection
that we had and the fence came down and
still nothing has changed
everything is different but nothing has
changed
liz cheney and adam kenzinger are being
lauded
as courageous heroes and while i agree
with that notion
why because they told the truth yeah
why is telling the truth hard
i guess in this america it is
us for officers we would do january 6
all over again we wouldn't stay home
because we knew it was going to happen
we would show up that's courageous
that's heroic so what i ask from you all
is to get to the bottom of what happened
and that includes
like i echoed the sentiments of all the
other officers sitting here
i use an analogy to describe
what i want as a hit man if a hit man
is hired and he kills somebody the
hitman goes to jail
but who hired him man go to jail but the
person who hired them does right
there was an attack carried out on
january 6th
and a hit man sent them i want you to
get to the bottom of that
thank you well uh
thank you very powerful comments by the
way um
cameron thompson yes if i may i
uh i also would like to
also for you guys to give us the tools
or at least the
things we need to succeed to continue to
protecting you guys
that's uh i think that's essential
for you guys to provide us what we need
in terms of life financially
um i don't know i'm not part of the
in window about how that process works
but
perhaps fortifying fortifying the
capital that will help
i know we were literally desperate
if we had that that would have made a
big difference on general
six i know people want to keep this
place
open to the public as much as possible
but there are things that we could do
to remove that and also or to reinforce
entrances what not it's hard
but it takes will i know
i could tell the capital has some
regulations why not but the time has
passed
we still have security measures from
20 years ago that had to go we need to
reinvent the wheel
and change that but only you guys have
the power to authorize that
they won't do unless you guys do the
same the other thing is
we still only operating on
certain things that we could adjust
things that we were doing back in
when 9 11 happen we're still doing it
today
even six months after the attack on the
capital
but only you perhaps with the chief of
police the new chief of police which
he seems we too
just like officer don said we still
don't think that
prior january 6 we were doing it and
we're still doing it today
and i think that should change
thank you wow well again thank all of
you for your your testimony
and obviously you are real heroes in
this
situation uh what you did in
in the committee's uh opinion
helped preserve this democracy the time
you gave
for reinforcements to finally get to the
capitol
made the difference uh so for that we
thank you
but you carried out your duties at
tremendous risk
now we on this committee have a duty
however a far less dangerous one but an
essential one to get to the bottom
of what happened that day we cannot
allow what happened on january
6 to ever happen again we owe it to the
american people
we owe it to you and your colleagues and
we will not
fail i assure you and that
responsibility
thank you again to our witnesses
uh as well as our distinguished
colleagues of the committee
uh any closing remarks
without objections members will be
permitted
10 business days to submit statements
for the record
including opening remarks and additional
questions for witnesses
to appropriate staff at all meetings of
the select committee
without objection the committee stands
to join
we will be continuing to cover this
january 6th
committee it is extremely important i
want to thank people who supported
today's stream and we are going to be
back
with more i want to say thanks to olivia
julius
as well as uh anders garlad both of whom
who signed up
on my website i would really appreciate
if you
signed up at joinedpakman.com we have
this coupon code myhipa which you can
use to get a
heavily discounted membership we really
depend on your support these are going
to be some long days we're doing our
regular show
and we're covering the committee also on
twitch
i want to say thanks to everybody and by
the way thanks to all the new hundreds
of new twitch followers during this
stream
um i want to say thanks to people who
signed up with twitch prime sock queen
pink and blonde glitteriest dreadhead
devop bar jen here demastered debater
herp z the hoosier daddy
sarierblue dustan short brief
lagubrious miller reppa
noodle mixing sound and mikey gaming
that's 15 people
putting us at 17 and you do have to
spell the coupon code correctly on my
website hipaa often misspelled with
two p's it is one p and one a
and uh your continued support will make
it possible for us to keep covering uh
the hearings
uh tomorrow and ongoing in addition to
the daily show really really important
stuff here
and uh so much important testimony we
see adam schiff here in the foreground
i believe that's congressman aguilar to
adam schiff's right
there is adam kinzinger to the right of
aguilar and then uh congressman thompson
in the back there alt i think i hope i'm
identifying these people correctly
um speaking to the to the four police
officer
witnesses um this is not jack dorsey
here by the way this is a police officer
who testified very very powerfully um
and a lot of very very important things
going on here let's look at a few super
chats i do want to look at just a few
super chats here
um i swore an oath to the constitution
in 2002 to begin my service it's
painfully obvious now that many who take
the oath don't understand or give a damn
about it
i assumed all felt the weight of that
oath but no
that's joe wouldn't it be ironic if
trump deletes his emails showing his
planning of january 6th
russia if you're listening trump doesn't
use email
interestingly enough the officer
basically said he wanted trump held
accountable god i wish that would happen
gop is full of sick
sick people indeed can lauren bobert be
charged with a crime for tweeting nancy
pelosi's location during the
insurrection probably not
probably not um is fox news
covering this uh no they they were very
busy with other things
sir your wife is up in the air has to be
antifa losers don't grow chad beards
the commission is meant to get to the
bottom of what caused the insurrection
all that is happening is more of the
same pageantry well remember
there are going to be other witnesses on
other topics including the genesis and
inspiration for the riots
upcoming so we're just not there yet
we're not there yet
uh let's see pac-man i'm from boston i'm
on lunch break
trump's got to give raskin comb-over
tips
republicans have already prepared their
opposing argument a careful curation of
facts officially known in legal circles
as the
what about black lives matter defense
like a bloody zombie raid no brain only
hateful purpose
remember it was all antrifa disguised as
trump supporters
except ashley babbitt she was a poor
innocent patriot am i doing it right
yeah basically basically that that's
essentially the argument that uh
we are going to hear from republicans
a couple little things to show you guys
just you know it's a very serious day um
the other day jimmy from philly did a
whole like four hour stream and a lot of
it was about me
but check out jimmy from philly's room i
was not surprised to see that jimmy from
philly is a hoarder
see if anybody comes
this is really depressing
get somebody
oh one person like his is the mattress
is crazy
there's stuff so there's like a plate of
cookies or
i mean
no i didn't call him he
uh
one of my subs told me that he uh what
did he do he
uh
he relates the story the four black guys
taking my sign
signs but he lies he says
jimmy changed chased four black
teenagers he's talking about me right
now
in philadelphia first of all i never
said they were teenagers
they were young men
20-somethings i said that
in the call with them that's right
20-something-year-old black man
anyway this is like really really really
depressing this is jimmy from philly for
people who don't know
and i'm i would really like to do a uh
sort of like an intervention with jimmy
with dr k
i think that that would be a good thing
to do so anyway i'm not going to show
you too much more of that
this is another person apparently has
taken the term
giga cringe this is some kind of
streamer named sneaky
check this out that's so classic for c9
i feel like so many times in split we've
seen them like
get bearings and seventeen and then oh
my god if i has a flash
don't wait really yep are you serious
really
that was giga cringe what
so giga cringe continues to spread
and then lastly uh i did show
my second eggplant on instagram if you
follow me on instagram you would have
seen this already
um yeah david.pacman on instagram this
is my second eggplant
it does violate hipaa this is a
violation of hipaa
and um anyway yeah my hair is up in the
air
sir your wife is up in the air sir sure
yep so anyway um fraud no it's a real
eggplant
real eggplant so that that's all um
that's all been happening there that's
what's been going on okay
uh will i play league of legends no i
don't even know what that means
i do want to say a big thank you to
betta
rissa who just signed up on my website
joinpakman.com very much appreciate your
support
of the committee streams very very
important stuff
um yeah a lot going on and there's going
to continue to be more
also want to say thanks to biden silence
for the twitch prime subscription number
19 today
um and oh we've got a few membership
dumps coming in
ken o'hara just signed up at
joinedpakman.com with the coupon code
my hipaa very much appreciate that big
massive dumps
exactly and i guys i'm telling you
the code is working people don't know
how to spell hipaa
okay you must spell it correctly i'm
going to prove it to you right now
it's my h-i-p-a-a
it's two a's and there you go
okay you've got to spell people think
it's like hippo is in hippopotamus
it's not it's not miss kimberly says
jimmy from philly looks like he lives in
a group home or halfway house yeah i
know
it's really depressing matty sancho says
an orange trump shirt that's not ironic
at all
i know it's it's all it's all beyond
parody
quite frankly um an
incredibly bizarre day oh and let me do
a few
unban requests all right we have
unbanned requests
okay uh i let's let's take a look at it
a user named
dl espinoza
um
said pelosi has a foot in the grave
what's the latest on quomosexual and who
is the fugly redhead
they were then timed out they then said
what is this a freaking soap opera
please play some violins in response to
the officer testimony
they were banned and their unban
requests
was 10 american flag icons and 20 middle
finger icons that is a deny
and a perma-ban this is not live guys
the testimony is over you're not missing
anything the testimony
is over this is not live next unbanned
request
is a user named irradunat
who said is this one of the channels too
insecure to handle opposing opinions you
effing nerds are pathetic you don't
matter you have no lives clinging
together as cyber personalities grow up
oh they're gonna give us wedgies like in
high school
quick ban them before my anxiety kicks
in
beta girl there is a reason you guys
don't get laid
okay so they were banned their unban
request was you
effing are hilarious no
self-respect society laughs at your
insignificance
super beta that is a deny
and permaban and then lastly a user who
goes by the name
beastbeardtv
who says uh
dear god let's see what they said
hipaa f the vaccines we never needed
them as kids and we still don't
hipa that wasn't just a truth they were
banned for spreading anti-vaxx
propaganda they then had an unbanned
request
lol can't handle the truth even my
kids didn't need vaccines when they got
viruses
so why ban me for sharing a truth
i can still watch and i'm sure there are
other chats sharing info like this too
that is a deny and that is a perma-ban
all right guys it's just we're just not
gonna take it you know there's
all of the there's a really funny thing
too where people think we're going to
lose our audience because we ban a few
people
the rate at which the audience is
growing dramatically exceeds banning
three to five people a day
i want to say thanks to frank dougherty
for signing up at joinedpakman.com with
the coupon code myhipa
also want to say thanks to sam brake for
signing up on my website with the coupon
code
my hipaa thank you to everybody
for joining me today get off my stream
to the trolls and we will be back
tomorrow
with more of the january 6th commission
moment of the sexual experience will ask
the young lady who's your daddy
this should be remixed if officer akimov
is watching
this could be the next remix masterpiece
dude because just wait till you see what
happens here oh officer officer akimov
is here
uh that's beautiful
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
[Music]
i'm joined today by pastor james davis
is the most successful pimp on planet
earth
to reverence the word of god to trust it
to preach it
[Music]
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
[Music]
george bush and george bush jr have been
penetrated
by at least 100 men in their anus 100
200 000 strong i didn't do it that's
not my problem oh i got down on my knees
[Music]
and tons and tons of live
and loads of money and tons and tons of
lives